Daniel Jeremiah star the NFL Network
Network analysts their Chargers color
analyst and worked with the Ravens
Browns and Eagles as a scout you can see
Daniel the path to the draft Monday
through Friday at 8:00 Eastern on NFL
Network Daniel where are you right now I
am I am in the family room Dan there's a
puzzle that's been about 80% complete
next to me for the last four weeks that
is yet to be completed and and I'm just
sitting out here by myself my kids are
all still asleep because apparently
we're doing night school over here or
they finish up like at 11:00 and then I
didn't go to bed where are you going to
be doing the draft room in your house
I'll be in my office which is about 15
paces away I was going to do you know
how Gordon does like the carpool karaoke
like get a ride to work I was gonna do
one for myself from my closet to my
office but the episode would last about
six seconds so I didn't think it would
be all that good I know that people are
looking at this virtual draft and saying
that this should be easy to pull off
because the teams are on remote anyway
but you can have conference calls or you
know you can have a conference call line
there but if you were part of what you
know one of those Scouts for one of
these teams like what could you see as a
possible hiccup with this aside from
just you know technologically if a line
goes down or the internet goes down well
I would say there's there's some people
that you talk to that not not really any
concerns at all and there's others that
are concerned I've been in rooms where
it's done differently Dan I think that
if you're doing it right in terms of you
know how you stack the board where you
are with medical information on players
all that stuff should be done ahead of
time so I mean literally you you're in
the room and you your general manager
has the list the order of the players
you know the kind of guys you'd want to
trade up for those have been highlighted
all that will pay is in the barn and so
it's a little bit easier to pull off but
there are other teams where you'll be on
the clock and they'll ask the doctor
well do you really think we shouldn't
take this guy like oh that decision
should have been made oh yeah yeah we
don't maybe talking about that now so I
think that's that's the difference
between those but the the one area that
everybody agrees will be a little bit
tricky and that's why I think they're
going to
scrimmage it is is the trades but again
I think this is going to place a greater
importance on getting that worked out or
ironed out now and people will say oh
you can't do that you don't know what's
going to happen well you can because if
I'm picking 17 and on the Cowboys I
would call every team that's picking
ahead of you before the draft starts and
just say hey under a scenario where
there's a player that we want that's in
your pick and you are not happy what's
with what's there and you would look to
get back let's work out what that
parameters of that trade would look like
and you're going to get that all down
now so then if that pops up you don't
have to start at the very beginning of
the process because I just think would
be very difficult to pull off which team
do you think changes the draft
I think Miami is the team because they
hold all the cards with as many pixs
they have and the fact that they need a
quarterback you know will they try and
go up or will they be patient and sit
and wait at number five to see who falls
to them that to me that changes the
complexion of the draft and it's really
interesting because right behind them
you have the Chargers and those two
teams are the two that you know along
with the Bengals are the quarterback
team so that that to me Miami kind of
holds some keys there to what happens I
had a source tell me yesterday don't get
played by you know these rumors of the
Dolphins are interested in Justin
Herbert and and I said hey I'm just
reporting what some people are reporting
do you believe the Dolphins if I ask
them right now who are you interested in
most interested in it do you think they
have a definitive answer um yeah I would
always say my gut says yes that that
Chris Grier knows what they're going to
do but there's there's been reports in
the past of teams deciding you know two
days before the draft which is crazy to
me but I know Chris a little bit and I
think he would have that he would have
that answer by this point in time all I
all I say on the Herbert to a thing is
you know I talked to people that are
very connected inside that building and
they say there is support for - and
their support for Herbert and I think
that the two of medical thing is what
kind of puts a wrench in it if tool was
100%
healthy might you know I would probably
go with okay this Herbert stuff is
smokescreen but the fact that is that
it's a different case with this help so
that's why I actually buy into the fact
that I think Herbert's in play there I
do too because I'm just looking at this
logically which is probably the wrong
approach and that is you don't know
about tua that there it's a there's a
great unknown and if you're going to
move up to get him or if I take somebody
who I think is this sure thing
then you know or at least he's healthy
Justin Herbert doesn't have a trail of
injuries like to it does if they're both
you know healthy then to is going to the
dolphins I would imagine but it feels
like every year you have the rise and
fall of quarterbacks you know couple of
weeks ago Jordan love then you had
Justin Herbert who was getting it now
it's two of the rise in the fall with
two up Joe borough is separated himself
from this but it feels like every draft
we build up a quarterback and then we
start to tear him down a little bit
before the draft no I think there's
something to that and I would say I
compared the Dolphins decision you know
if you have to it Herbert remember so I
guess it's still one let's make a deal
like I I don't I don't think that you
know I don't think Herbert has this
incredible incredible upside I've
compared him to like the dishwasher
which you can see the dishwasher it's a
nice dishwasher not necessarily in love
with the dishwasher but you know what it
is
that's Herbert and then to is what's
behind the curtain and you don't know if
that's a week vacation the Bahamas or a
broom you know that's why the no one
person the unknown I want I want honest
answers here I want I want you to tell
me the downside to Joe burrow is what he
does not have a huge arm and if you were
going to say what would the concern be
well you know some people will say that
handful of games you might play in
really bad weather and Cincinnati and
that division that that would be a
challenge for him I don't tend to see
that as an issue I think his other his
other attributes are so off the charts
you know accuracy decision-making poise
he can create plays he's got the best
vision of any quarterback I've seen you
know that that to me is what makes him
special his though to see the whole
field so you're gonna run a system that
fits him you're not going to just throw
him into any system and have him be
successful but you had the blueprint
last year with what they did at LSU and
I think that Zach Taylor has the
capabilities of implementing what he
does with mixed was what LSU did and I
think it would be a perfect fit
Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network analyst
he'll be working the draft with our
buddy Rich Eisen on the NFL Network in
conjunction with ESPN the downside to
Justin Herbert is he just he's a little
bit robotic and there's not as much
natural play making with him in other
words when it's when it's on time and
rhythm on script I think he's you know
he's a good quarterback that's why I
like him going to a place that can run
the football play action and he'll be
successful but he's not going to sit
back there and and and carve you up with
with bodies coming in his face he's not
going to be able to use his athleticism
and creativity to make a lot of plays
that way even though he's really
athletic there's a difference between
being athletic and being creative and
he's just not very creative as a
football player but you are getting
somebody that's incredibly intelligent
and is going to be again I say a high
floor man I think you know exactly what
you're getting with him aside from the
injuries with Toa what would be the big
negative for you you know he's not the
biggest guy in the world so there's some
size stuff there but man I don't know
there's not a lot to hit on him that
that's negative because you know again I
keep coming back decision-making
accuracy poise I Keith he's so good in
those key key areas he's I talk to GM
the other day that said he's the you
know not like we've had a long era of
this but he said he's the best RPO
quarterback that I've ever seen you know
just ball handling you know get the ball
out he'll hit those slanted zillion
times over as NFL is start to
incorporate more and more of the RPO
game this guy's got a master's degree in
that Jordan love he's the best natural
thrower
in the draft if you had a game of horse
between all the quarterbacks he would
win because he can make any throw from
any platform you know falling away he
can do any arm angle he
do any of that stuff but but they keep
again I go through that same formula
when I'm putting the final touches on
the grades for these guys and although
you account for the number of starters
that were lost you account for the new
system I get all that but
decision-making was just not good this
year and and that to me is what you
worry about a little bit going forward
he's got to clean that up he needs more
time than these top four quarterbacks he
sees the fourth one for me now but to me
the if he goes to the right spot and he
has he has the most ability do you think
the Chargers are would they make a big
move here to move up to get to I I think
they could and and and that's from you
know not working there talking to people
there that just from observing how they
were in free agency not notoriously
super aggressive and free agency and
they were you know they were all in on
the copper 80 thing and then they went
out and were aggressive signing some
other players with Chris Harris and they
did a nice job going I'll get Brian
belaga to trying to upgrade the
offensive line so it just seemed like an
aggressive approach so if you're going
to be aggressive and free agency that
leads me to believe you'd be willing to
be aggressive in the draft and everybody
in the league those what the position
they need to address so that to me is
well I think I could see them being
aggressive to move up do you think the
Redskins were ever interested in a
quarterback I don't I don't know it to
me it seems like this is a fairly easy
decision for them because they have
Haskins who has a lot of ability and you
have another quarterback you just traded
to bring over there who they like as a
coaching staff at Calallen so you've got
two guys nothing's really decided there
and then and then where you are you
don't have a really clean you know with
to it with the injury assuming burrow is
gone it's not like he's the cleanest
quarterback so why not try and figure
out what you have in your own building
and oh yeah by the way bring in the best
player in the draft who's going to give
you one of the one of the best defensive
lines and all of football for Ron Rivera
and Jack Del Rio I mean that to me that
just seems like an easy one just take
chase young and get let this quarterback
thing breathe for a little bit yeah but
I don't know if this makes sense to you
but if Kyle Allen beats out Dwayne
Haskins does
that mean that the Redskins should have
taken to her if the main Haskins can't
beat Kyle Allen then are they making a
mistake well I think that's a fair
argument although it would be on brand
to have the Redskins have a later grab
quarterback read out the first-round
quarterback you know look my thing is
Nana I know it's it's the most important
position and you've got to get that
figured out if tool was clean then I
would I could make that case and say
look he's better than what you have just
take him but because of some of the
injuries stuff and there's a little bit
of a question mark there JC I'm just too
good yeah I mean I can't most important
it's the second most important position
in football is who can get to the
quarterback and you have an elite player
just fallin in your lap right here just
take him I'll leave you with this if you
could get a totally honest answer with
Tom Brady on any topic deflategate Bill
Belichick Robert Kraft or something else
or other what would you want to know
about oh I would this is can be kind of
a weird question but I would say how
many you know to put him on if we put
you on one of the like let's say because
I work there Tom if you were the
quarterback of the Baltimore Ravens with
their personnel
how many Super Bowls would you have one
there I bet you if you told the truth
he'd say ten
yeah I mean look at the personnel Dan
compare the personnel of those two teams
outside of the quarterback position for
that four mm decade like I don't I think
they would he want ten Super Bowls Wow
okay
so I mean you put you've got you've got
you know this tweet people might forget
about this but you've got you've got
they arguably the greatest middle
linebacker of all time arguably the
greatest free safety of all time you've
got Terrell Suggs is probably a Hall of
Famer
you've got Haloti Ngata who is a
perennial Pro Bowler you've got Chris
McAllister you've got the one top three
left tackle in NFL history and Jonathan
Ogden a home a tiny yard rusher yeah
you've got a Hall of Fame Titan plus his
backup Todd people's a perennial Pro
Bowler a tooth
yard rusher you don't think Tom Brady
wouldn't want I think he would want ten
Super Bowls I don't think that's crazy
anyone six with the guys we had no
English he just blew my mind there
that's gonna go viral here Daniel that
that one that's pretty good and you work
how the Ravens yeah we saw how many we
you know we couldn't beat him and we
would look at the rosters on on paper
and go we feel pretty good about every
everyone but this guy and let's go and
top it that's good stuff
it's great to check in with you
hopefully we'll talk to you prior to the
draft again if not have fun I'll be
texting you probably during the draft oh
you're the best then I appreciate you
buddy
Thank You Daniel Daniel Jeremiah NFL
Network analyst Chargers color analyst